county superintendent dr jesus jarrah's
job may be on the line as some trustee
members are hoping to terminate his
contract that vote is set to take place
later this week victoria saha joining us
live now from the newsroom with reaction
on this victoria
this agenda item was brought on by three
trustee members though it does not list
exactly who but tonight i'm learning
that one of them is trustee danielle
ford i spoke with her and parents about
what they hope will happen to the leader
of one of the largest school districts
in the nation
on thursday trustees will discuss and
possibly take action on termination for
convenience on superintendent jesus
jarrah's contract trustee danielle ford
says it's time to discuss superintendent
jarrah's role with the school district
legally she wasn't able to say much but
tells us in a statement more concerns
than usual have been coming in from
parents and staff about his leadership
and i believe it warrants discussing
whether he is the best fit for
superintendent of the nation's fifth
largest school district or not the best
news i've heard in weeks parent
christopher wagner is echoing some of
those concerns after wanting answers
from the school district regarding the
uptick in violence in schools i could
not even get a response from the
superintendent
they wouldn't even acknowledge the
issues that are going on jarrah was
first appointed to superintendent of the
clark county school district back in
june of 2018.
one parent thinks ousting jarrah will
not fix anything there's a lot of finger
pointing there's a lot of blaming
instead of just coming together and
helping him finish out his term in the
most positive way jarrah was asked about
his job during a press conference on
friday i work for every single day
for the children and the educators that
i work alongside
that's my main focus that continues to
be my focus and that will remain my
focus until i'm told otherwise
back in may the board trustees approved
an extension to drawers contract with
hopes he would continue his role until
2023 the board of trustees will hold
their meeting this thursday to discuss
the matter reporting from the newsroom
victoria saha live local now